Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir blicken auf die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Da ist so einiges passiert. Es ist eng, eng, eng in dieser Liga. Ach, ich freu mich auf die Sendung. Jetzt gleich hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass, Nummer 192. Und natürlich bin ich nicht alleine hier. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Aber um mich geht's hier nicht. Es geht um meine Gäste und ich freue mich sehr auf diese Runde. Zum einen Kirsten vom Weserfunk. Einem Werder Bremen-Podcast, den ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen möchte. Ed Kirste-Pinkie auf Twitter. Hallo Kirsten.
Moin.
Ja, schön hier. So alte Podcast-Legenden jetzt ja inzwischen fast schon, kann man sagen. Oder den Weserfunk gibt es jetzt schon eine ganze Weile.
Den Weserfunk gibt es schon eine ganze Weile. Wir haben jetzt gestern unsere 151. Folge aufgenommen. Wir waren so bis zum Einstieg in die 2. Liga, waren wir immer relativ unregelmäßig unterwegs. Aber wir haben uns jetzt ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt. Es sind mehr Leute da. Und jetzt machen wir jede Woche Aufnahme. Und außerdem haben wir jetzt auch noch –da sind wir ein bisschen stolz drauf –ein neues Format angefangen, was wir ab und zu mal machen, was sich mit Werder auch beschäftigt, aber nicht nur. Das ist unsere Mixed Zone. Und da haben wir die neue Aufsichtsrätin Ulrike Hiller in der ersten Folge gehabt, mit der wir über Werder und alles Mögliche gesprochen haben. Also wenn euch das interessiert, hört rein.
Mensch, das klingt alles ziemlich gut. Ich habe noch eine Frage an euch beide, bevor wir dann ja auch noch über ein paar andere Vereine sprechen müssen an dieser Stelle. Raphael, du darfst mal anfangen. Was würde denn passieren, wenn Schalke den Aufstieg verpassen würde?
Dann werden Mitarbeiter erstmal aus der Geschäftsstelle gehen, müssen nur noch auf Gehalt verzichten müssen. Dann werden Spieler wie Thomas Auwian und Kio Itakura nicht zu halten sein. Auwian wird dann vielleicht trotzdem gekauft, weil Schalke sich dann einen Mehrwert erhofft durch einen Verkauf wiederum. Offiziell sagte auch Peter Knebel, der Sportvorstand von Schalke, dass die Planung vorsieht, innerhalb der nächsten drei Jahre aufzusteigen. Die Erfahrung zeigt aber –Grüße gehen raus nach Hamburg –dass es ja nicht einfacher wird nach dem ersten Jahr. Ich will damit gar nicht sagen, dass es im ersten Jahr deswegen einfach ist oder einfach her. Aber es wird natürlich dann halt noch schwieriger, weil die finanzielle Situation kennt jeder. Ich glaube auch, jeder, der nicht so viel mit Schalke am Hut hat, ist halt sehr, sehr schwierig. Und da muss man auch schauen, ob zum Beispiel in Simonterode noch viel länger bleibt. Salazar wird auf jeden Fall gekauft. Da bekommt Frankfurt erst nach 2022 eine Rückkaufoption. Aber Churlinov geht definitiv auch zurück nach Stuttgart. Also dann folgt ja an der einen oder anderen Stelle auch der nächste Umbruch. Und dann ist die Frage, wie gut es dann wieder gelingt, alle zusammenzuhalten. Und dann ist auch die Frage, ob es nicht schon wieder einen Trainerwechsel geben wird. Weil der Vertrag von Ramozes läuft halt nur bis Sommer. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass jetzt zu früh, weil Schalke aus den Fehlern der Vergangenheit gelernt hat, unter anderem auch mit den fünf Trainern der vergangenen Saison, mit ihm verlängern wird. Sondern es knallhart wahrscheinlich miteinander verknüpfen wird, ob Schalke Erfolg hat, sprich wieder aussteigen wird. Und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann ist auch der Trainer weg. Und dann bin ich sehr gespannt, wer dann die richtige Lösung sein soll. Weil ich gebe ganz offen zu, Schalke hatte jetzt so viele verschiedene Trainertypen in den vergangenen fünf Jahren, dass ich dann jetzt nicht um die Ecke kommen kann und sagen kann, ja, der ist dann auf jeden Fall der Richtige und mit dem klappt es dann. Also wird dann wahrscheinlich wieder ein kleiner Umbruch erfolgen. Und deswegen bin ich dann skeptisch, dass es im zweiten Jahr eher klappen soll als im ersten.
Kirsten, wie ist es bei Werder?
Also finanziell müssen wir eigentlich aufsteigen. Da geht es uns wie Schalke. Weil sonst wird weiter gespart werden müssen. Ich glaube, so rein von der Mannschaft spielerisch wäre das jetzt für uns nicht so das Riesenproblem noch ein zweites Jahr oder ein drittes Jahr in der zweiten Liga zu verbringen. Weil wir haben eigentlich so gut wie alle aus dem Kader aussortiert also beziehungsweise sind verkauft, die nicht Bock auf 2. Liga hatten. Marco Friedl und Milos Veljkovic, Milos Veljkovic läuft der Vertrag aus zum Ende der Saison. Aber Marco Friedl könnte man dann immer noch verkaufen, das heißt, da gibt es dann halt auch immer nochmal Geld. Jiri Pavlenka wird definitiv gehen, der Vertrag läuft auch aus, der wird auch vermutlich nicht verlängern. Ich glaube aber, dass wir eine ganze Menge Spieler haben, die bleiben würden und wir auch mit jungen Spielern dann auffüllen können, die dann doch ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung haben, was die ganze Sache wieder ein bisschen spannend macht. Aber ich würde es jetzt nicht super als den Super-Gau empfinden, wenn wir jetzt nicht direkt wieder aufsteigen.
Gut, ich meine, wir müssen da ja eh alle spekulieren. Das hat mich jetzt nur interessiert. Ich wollte jetzt gar nicht die Stimmung runterziehen mit dieser Frage. Ich merke schon, jetzt hat diese Sendung auf einmal so eine Schwere gewonnen. Ist ja auch gar nicht so weit. Ich weiß genau, wie wir jetzt wieder gute Laune bekommen, indem wir über den ersten Eftel Nürnberg sprechen. Raphael, die hast du ja unter anderem jetzt dann beim 4-1-Zieg der Schalker und aus Nürnbergersicht logischerweise dann eine 1-4-Niederlage näher beobachtet. Welchen Eindruck macht denn der Klub auf dich?
Ja, schon sehr gut. Ich finde, er ist einmal das Endergebnis ja auch ein bisschen über das tatsächliche Spiel hinweg. Es stand, jetzt weiß ich es nicht mehr ganz genau, bis zur 86. Minute, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall kurz vor Schluss, ja auch nur 2 zu 1 für Schalke. Und ich würde wirklich sagen, dass das Endergebnis dann zwei Tore zu hoch ausfiel. Schalke hat verdient gewonnen, meiner Meinung nach. Übrigens auch dann erst zum zweiten Mal gegen ein Team aus den Top 10. Ansonsten gelang ja nur gegen Paderborn noch ein 1 zu 0-Sieg. Der in Bremen, der wurde dann ja noch genommen sozusagen. Aber ansonsten hat ja Schalke immer ziemlich lange Gesichter machen müssen gegen die Teams von oben. Und das war dann schon, glaube ich, dann auch so ein Statement, weil Nürnberg meiner Meinung nach wirklich auch keinen schlechten Ball spielt. Ich glaube nicht, dass es unter dem Strich reichen wird, um dann tatsächlich ganz am Saisonende noch einen Relegationsplatz mitzuspielen. Aber da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich alle einig, dass wir auch vielleicht nicht gedacht haben, dass Nürnberg eine bislang so gute Rolle spielt in der Saison. Und es hat ja auch ein bisschen gebraucht, bis die Klubberer dann tatsächlich auch ins Laufen gekommen sind. Aber ja, sieht eigentlich alles unter dem Strich tatsächlich nicht schlecht aus. Das hätte auch gut und gerne in die andere Richtung rausgehen können.
Wenn ich mir so angucke, Kirsten, Nürnberg, im Vergleich zu eben den Mitaufstiegskonkurrenten, dann hat man die drittbeste Abwehr. Da teilt man sich aber das positive Schicksal mit dem HSV. Die haben die beste Abwehr. Darmstadt, Zweitbeste, Paderborn, St. Pauli, Schalke sind alle in diesem Bereich. Da sprechen wir von 23, 21 und 20 Toren. Der Unterschied scheint mir dann aber vor allem der Sturm zu sein. Denn da sind alle genannten sehr stark. Über Darmstadt und St. Pauli habe ich schon gesprochen. Jan Regensburg, Schalke 04, Werder sind dann die Nächsten der HSV. Und der 1. FC Nürnberg kommt dann aber erst deutlich später. Er hat erst 27 Tore erzielt, was der größte Unterschied zu sein scheint. Könnte das dann auch daran scheitern? Ist das nur eine Momentaufnahme? Was ist dein Gefühl, wenn du den Club dir anschaust?
Also ich glaube auch, die schießen echt wirklich wenig Tore. Und das ist irgendwo dann, wenn man aufsteigen will, vielleicht ein bisschen hinderlich. Ich habe die eigentlich auch vor der Saison wieder so mehr so im Mittelfeld angesiedelt. Ich glaube auch, dass sie sich da dann zum Ende der Saison hin auch wieder einnisten werden. Weil also, wenn die jetzt nicht irgendwie noch da groß was tun, ist das also mit den Touren, die sie schießen, halt wird es einfach echt schwer.
Also Top-Torjäger sind Zhurunov und Dovidan mit jeweils fünf Treffern. Und genauso war es auch schon, als wir, ich weiß gar nicht vor wie vielen Wochen, mit Flo Zenger über den Club gesprochen haben. Da hat er genau das schon gesagt, dass der Torjäger fehlt. Manuel Schäffler war das ja in der letzten Saison. Und damals war es schon, dass Zhurunov und Dovidan, die jeweils besten Spieler waren, vom Ergebnis her im Sturm. Haben aber halt jeweils fünf Tore gemacht. Das ist halt, scheint mir so, der größte Stolperstein für den FCN zu sein. Also da können wir mal gucken, wie sich das entwickelt. Noch hängt ja der Clubweitiger mit seinen 30 Punkten in dieser dicken Verlangs- und Torjäger. Torjäger kann man ja vielleicht auch manchmal in der Transferperiode zur Rückrunde hin finden. Ich finde, Torjäger integrieren sich manchmal schneller in eine Mannschaft als andere Spieler, die man verpflichtet. Also ja, vielleicht ist da noch was drin für den 1. FC Nürnberg. Wir machen weiter, weil so sehr in die Tiefe können wir jetzt da auch gar nicht gehen, wie es sowieso jede Mannschaft verdient hätte. Wir wollen doch auf Dynamo Dresden blicken. Über die haben wir schon länger nicht mehr hier gesprochen, aber wir haben hier noch ein paar, die im Rasenfunk Kirsten, die liegen auf Platz 11 mit 22 Punkten, haben damit 5 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz und zuletzt eigentlich ganz gute Partien gemacht von den Ergebnissen her. Also aus den letzten 5 Spielen 3 Siege, 2 Niederlagen. Das heißt, 9 dieser 22 Punkte hat man da sich holen können. Meinem Eindruck nach ist Dresden jetzt auch ein bisschen in der Rolle angekommen, die man ihnen schon vorher zugetraut hat, nämlich als der Aufsteiger, der es schafft, auch mal gegen vermeintliche Favoriten zu gewinnen. Zum Beispiel gegen den KSC zu Hause. Und damit sich dann die Punkte zu holen, die zum Klassenerhalt beitragen.
Ja, denke ich auch. Also ich glaube, Dresden ist auch ohne den jetzt irgendwie zu nahe treten wollen. Eine Mannschaft, die ganz viel über die Euphorie auch auf den Rängen kommt. Die haben ja, also jetzt von der politischen Einstellung mal abgesehen, einen sehr, sehr starken Anhang, der sehr, sehr stark anfeuert und der auch überall mit stark dabei ist. Und ich glaube, die kommen auch viel über diese Euphorie und können dann halt solche Sachen rausrauen, dass sie mal ein Team über sie, die über ihnen stehen, schlagen und sich da die entsprechenden Punkte holen. Da geht halt glaube ich auch sehr viel über den Kampf, der von der Euphorie angefeuert wird. Oh Gott, kling ich dummelig.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, was du meinst. Die Statistik dazu ist, dass Dresden in der F15 seine 22 Punkte zuhause geholt hat. Das stützt dich ja.
Ja, also das ist eine sehr kämpferische Mannschaft. Die hat auch einen ziemlich starken Willen. Und die kommt halt wirklich über die Euphorie. Ich glaube nicht, dass die jetzt über das schöne, spielerische kommt. Die kommen wirklich, die feuern sich über die Euphorie. Und wenn die ein Tor geschossen haben, dann werden die warm. Und dann lassen die auch nicht nach. Also es ist nicht so, wie das auch bei Werder zum Teil ist. Wenn sie dann ein Tor schießen, dass das dann alles läuft. Wir fangen uns dann ja immer noch Gegentore. Also jetzt nicht mehr. Jetzt verlieren wir sowas zum Glück nicht mehr. Also die letzten Spiele. Aber bei Werder ist das dann halt auch so gewesen, wenn wir ein Gegentor gefangen haben oder so. Oder wenn wir ein Tor geschossen haben und ein Gegentor gefangen haben, dass das dann alles auf einmal komplett bei Werder zum Erliegen gekommen ist. Und das habe ich bei Dresden irgendwie so nie den Eindruck. Bei denen habe ich immer wirklich den Eindruck, dass die bis zum Ende kämpfen.
Das ist Dynamo Dresden aus Sicht von Kirsten. Raphael, du hast Dynamo unter anderem erlebt bei einem 0-3 auf Schalke, wo ich jetzt die… Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war Dresden aber auch nicht drei Tore schlechter, oder habe ich das gerade völlig falsch abgespeichert?
Nee, nee, genau. Hast du vollkommen recht. Also Schalke hat sich da auch lange schwer getan. Und Dresden hat da auch sehr mutig gespielt. Und ich kann Markiessen nur zustimmen. Ich finde, dass Dresden einfach –das klingt jetzt auch ein bisschen blöd –dass es schon mehr weiß eigentlich, worauf sie sich einlassen sollten, was sie können und genau auch das umsetzen. Wenn ich das vergleiche mit den Kellerkindern, mit den aktuellen Kellerkindern. Also wenn ich Ingolstadt aure, Sandhausen sehe, sogar Hannover mit dabei. Dresden ist da einfach insgesamt ein bisschen stabiler unterwegs. Sie haben ja richtig stark angefangen. Da hatten sie zwar eine Delle, aber wie du ja auch gerade erwähnt hast, sie sind auch wieder zurückgekommen. Ja, dann gibt es vielleicht mal so Spiele wie 0-3 aus Schalke oder jetzt zuletzt 0-3 in Ingolstadt. Das, glaube ich, zählt dann auch wieder zu diesen Spielen, wo man sich danach an den Kopf fasst und sich denkt, wie konnte das denn jetzt sein, Ingolstadt bis dahin nur einmal gewonnen in 17 Spielen? Und dann gewinnt die da plötzlich so deutlich. Ich sehe das genauso wie Kirsten, leben extrem von der Euphorie, vom Kämpferischen. Aber genau das braucht es ja auch in der 2. Und gerade auch als Aufsteiger. Die Fanszene ist ja berüchtigt dafür. Ich muss auch gestehen, mir war auch ein bisschen von dem Schalke-Spiel da mulmig. Weil die Dresdner Fans –ich glaube, es schimpft sich, das meine ich gar nicht, dass BigTierlich Motto-Tag ausgerufen hatte für dieses eine Spiel. Und da gab es dann sehr, sehr viele Sicherheitsvorkehrungen. Man kennt ja auch viele andere Geschichten aus den Drehungen. Es kann auch sehr stimmungsvoll sein. Und das projiziert sich, glaube ich, total auf die Mannschaft. Und die saugt das aber auch auf und nutzt es tatsächlich. Und dann gibt es im Prinzip Hopp oder Top. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Dresden überhaupt unentschieden gespielt hat. Aber im Prinzip gibt es immer nur Siege oder Niederlagen.
Einmal haben sie unentschieden gespielt.
Ach ja, guck mal. Aber das zeigt ja schon, dass Dresden jetzt auch nicht zu diesen Teams zählt, dass sich irgendwie versteckt oder einigelt. Und so schließt sich der Kreis zu deiner Frage zu dem Schalke-Spiel. So war es nämlich auch nicht aus Schalke. Und ich finde, das kann man dann auch mal anerkennen. Und ich glaube, dass sie sich dann auch unterm Strich deswegen belohnt werden. Ob das jetzt deswegen zu einem souveränen Klassenerhalt reichen wird oder knapp vor dem Relegationsplatz, das sei mal dahingestellt. Aber ich sehe schon, da mindestens drei Teams auch unterm Strich schlechter als Dynamo.
Gehört denn da Hansa Rostock mit dazu, Raphael?
Ja, also zu den Teams, die dann um den Abstieg bangen müssen, meinst du?
Ja, also zu den Teams, die du schlechter als Dresden siehst.
Ja, ich finde schon, das sind keine riesigen Unterschiede. Aber ich habe das Spiel, zumindest jetzt Schalke-Rostock, ich muss jetzt auch gestehen, ob ich über Dresden oder Rostock rede, da kann ich mich immer nur auf entweder das Spiel gegen Schalke oder vielleicht noch ein, zwei weitere beziehen. Deswegen mögen mir die Anhänger es verzeihen, wenn ich das ein oder andere falsch einschätze. Aber rein subjektiv sehe ich Dynamo ein Ticken stabiler und besser auch als Hansa Rostock. Ich würde jetzt behaupten, dass Hannover 96 da noch irgendwie rauskommen wird, ohne weit nach vorne zu preschen in der Tabelle. Aber ich glaube schon, dass Rostock eher Probleme kriegen wird noch als Dynamo Dresden. Ich glaube, dass ganz unten das Feld noch ein bisschen enger zusammenrücken wird. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Ingolstadt und Auer wirklich so schwach weiterschwimmen wie in der Innenrunde.
Bei Rostock, Kirsten, sind, zumindest war das so der Stand, den wir in den letzten Kurzpässen hatten, vor allem die zugelassenen Schüsse, also die Defensive ein Problem. Als wir das letzte Mal aufgenommen haben, waren sie nach den Expected Goals der zugelassenen Chancen letzter in der Liga. Da wird es natürlich schwierig. 31 Gegentreffer in 18 Spielen ist jetzt auch gar nicht so wenig. Aber man hat ja auch drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz, den aktuell Sandhausen hat. Welchen Eindruck macht Rostock auf dich?
Also, ich finde auch, die sind halt... Ich habe jetzt echt nicht so viel Rostock gesehen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber ich glaube, die sind so ein bisschen wie Dresden, nur nicht so ganz euphorisch. Und ich sehe die eigentlich auch, dass die sich da so richtig schön noch in den Abstiegssumpf reinrummeln können. Weil Sandhausen irgendwie schaffen die das ja immer noch, in der letzten Minute sich zu retten, wie auch immer. Für Aue würde ich es mir tatsächlich wünschen, dass sie sich noch irgendwie zu retten. Weil ich möchte jetzt endlich auch mal noch nach Aue. In Goldstadt denke ich, die werden da bub-bye machen. Also die werden vermutlich wieder absteigen. Ich glaube nicht, dass die sich da noch richtig groß rauszummeln werden. Aber ich glaube, Rostock könnte sich richtig schön noch in den Abstiegssumpf reinspielen. Also dafür spielen die halt auch einfach nicht konstant genug.
Ist die Situation der Dresdner nicht so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit der der Bochumer in der ersten Liga? Ich finde, Bochum transportiert das auch total super rüber. Sie spielen jetzt auch nicht die Sterne vom Himmel, wirken aber extrem gefestigt und sehr kämpferisch. Sie spielen glaube ich auch sehr häufig nur Hopp oder Top. Kann man das ein bisschen vergleichen?
Also nach dem, was ich sehe, passt dieser Vergleich aktuell sehr gut, weil auch Bochum jetzt ein paar Spiele gewonnen hat, die man nicht unbedingt gewinnen muss. Auch weil Bochum eine sehr heimstärke Mannschaft ist und seine Punkte wesentlich daholt. Die Vergleiche finde ich nicht so falsch. Gleichzeitig hat man auch ähnliche Probleme beim Ausspielen von Kontern. Aber das sage ich jetzt bei Bochum auf Grundlage von 16 Spielen, die ich gesehen habe. Bei Dresden, zweite Liga, kann ich immer nur mal so reingucken. Deswegen weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich gerade den Dresdnern recht tue. Bei Rostock finde ich noch auffällig, welche Rolle Verhög spielt. Das ist ja was Positives. Zehn Tore hat er gemacht. Das ist, wenn man sich anguckt, dass Rostock insgesamt nur 21 erzielt hat. Ein ordentlicher, erklecklicher Anteil. Also das, was dem Club abgeht, das hat zumindest Hansa aus Rostock. Und etwas, das Ingolstadt ganz lange nicht hatte, haben sie jetzt am allerletzten Spieltag vor Weihnachten noch bekommen. Den ersten Sieg unter dem Trainer Rüdiger Rehm. Und wir haben es ja auch schon angesprochen. Im Dresdenteil 3 zu 0 gegen eben einen direkten Konkurrenten, nämlich Dynamo zu Hause. Damit hat man sieben Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz, zehn Punkte aufs rettende Ufer. Also es ist immer noch ein sehr großer Berg, den Ingolstadt da bezwingen müsste, um in dieser Liga zu bleiben. Aber Kirsten, steht der Sieg jetzt für etwas, was sich da verändert hat? Oder hast du das Gefühl, naja, das war halt so ein Ergebnis, wie es das halt manchmal gibt, dass man dann halt auch mal gewinnt, wenn keiner mehr damit rechnet. Aber im Grunde ist die Saison für Ingolstadt mehr oder weniger jetzt schon auf dritte Liga wieder ausgerichtet?
Also ich glaube, so sollte man ja nie als Fußballverein in die Rückrunde gehen. Aber ich glaube, dass tatsächlich dieser Sieg gegen Dresden zum nächsten Mal ein Ausreißer war, nach oben. Ich glaube, die werden nicht so ausreichend Punkten in der Rückrunde, dass sie da irgendwie noch die Klasse halten können. Weil vor allen Dingen jetzt auch so die Mannschaften, die oben spielen, also die 30 plus oder 29, 28 Punkte haben, sich alle jetzt ein bisschen eingegruft haben. Da gegen eine Überraschung zu machen, wird glaube ich relativ schwer werden in der Rückrunde für Ingolstadt.
Muss insofern vielleicht auch nicht so schlimm sein, weil wir in einer der früheren Ausgaben mal gelernt haben, dass 35 Prozent der Minuten, die gespielt wurden damals, das war der damalige Stand von Spielern, aus der U23 kamen. Und viele aus der 3. Liga sind eben noch mit dabei. Also Ingolstadt ist vielleicht auch ein Drittligist im Gewand eines Zweitligisten, womit man ja auch den Fall eines möglichen Abstiegs dann schon ganz gut mittelfristig abgefangen hat. Denn du hast wenige Spieler dann vermutlich mit dabei, die sagen würden, ich muss jetzt hier unbedingt weg, weil ich habe mir etwas komplett anderes davon versprochen, beim FCI zu spielen. Ja, stimmt, guter Punkt. Nur, dass sie nicht ihre besten Spieler noch abgeben mussten. Das kam bei Fürth noch mit dazu.
Ja gut, das kam bei Fürth dazu. Aber sie haben im Endeffekt eine Zweitligamannschaft in der ersten Liga gespielt.
Gibt es da was zu ergänzen aus deiner Sicht, Raphael?
Ich habe superoffen Punkte, was ich glaube auch, dass Ingolstadt sicherlich noch den einen oder anderen Punkt holen wird. Und auch wenn der Trainer wechselt, jetzt nochmal was anderes bewirkt, wenn ich mich an das Spiel zurückerinnere, auch Schalke, wo Schalke wirklich nicht gut gespielt hat. Das war auch wieder eins dieser Spiele, 3-0 am Ende. Das ist zwar ein bisschen zu hoch ausgefallen, aber was Ingolstadt da gespielt hat, das war schon ziemlich bieder. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das jetzt unter Rehm so viel ändern wird, dass es dann dazu reicht –ich glaube, sieben Punkte Rückstand sind es zumindest auf dem Remigrationsplatz –das einzuholen. Es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass Aue und Sandhausen in der Rückrunde auf dem Schrank schlagen werden und nichts mehr tun werden.
Ich glaube, da haben wir jetzt aber auch nicht so die Neuigkeit für alle Ingolstadt-Fans verkündet. Die werden jetzt nicht gerade vor Schreck ihre T-Tasse fallen gelassen haben. Noch kurz, um zu illustrieren, dieses Dynamo-Dresden-Spiel. Also es war schon wirklich ein besonderes Spiel. In der ersten Minute geht Ingolstadt in Führung durch Antonic. In der 17. Minute schießt Kevin Ehlers ein Eigentor. Dann steht es 0-2 aus Sicht der Dresdner, die fortan und auch schon vorher eigentlich den Ball haben. 72% Ballbesitz hat Dynamo Dresden. Und was haben sie aus diesem 72% Ballbesitz? Dann kreiert fünf Schüsse, davon einer aufs Tor. Also es war offensiv einfach ein Tag zum Vergessen für Dresden. Defensiv hat es Ingolstadt natürlich gut gemacht. Also Henne Ei, Frage, was da den größeren Ausschlag gegeben hat. Und in der 85. Minute gibt es da noch das 3-0. Und dann ist das Ding durch. Also so kam es zu diesem Sieg von Ingolstadt. Und das lässt ja dann auch schon einige Rückschlüsse zu. Auf Spielkultur und so weiter.
Das passt doch dann eigentlich ganz gut auch zu dem, was wir gerade über Dynamo Dresden gesagt haben. Das war dann jetzt ein Ausreißer. Das war einfach wahrscheinlich kein gelungener Tag. Und trotzdem hat man das Gefühl, dann wird halt Dynamo wieder in einem anderen Spiel die Kurve kriegen. Weil es einfach solche Spiele gibt, die haben ja auch andere Teams. Also ich würde jetzt behaupten, 16 oder 17 von den 18 Teams haben mal richtig ins Klo gegriffen. Das fragt man selbst beim Tabellenführer jetzt nach St. Pauli mit dem 0-3 in Kiel. Also ich glaube, es gibt immer wieder solche Tage, dass wir immer noch Bremen und Schalke feststellen in der Rückrunde. Ich bleibe einfach dabei, die Kurve wieder zu kriegen.
Sehr gut, dann lassen wir das als Schlusswort stehen. Es geht am 14. Januar weiter. Die 2. Liga beginnt nach der 1. Liga. Die darf schon früher starten. Das heißt, längere Winterpause nicht nur für die Vereine, sondern auch für euch beide, bei denen ich mich sehr bedanke. Danke, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich fand das sehr schön, auch mal die Parallelen zwischen Werder und Schalke zu sehen und dann doch auch die Unterschiede. Vielen, vielen Dank an Kirsten vom Weserfunk. At kirstepinky auf Twitter. Danke dir, Kirsten, dass du mal im Rasenfunk dabei warst. Und ebenfalls großen Dank an Raphael Wiesweg von ruhr24.de. Danke dir, Raphael, für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit in diesem Rasenfunk-Jahr. Es kann sein, dass das hier die letzte Aufnahme des Kalenderjahres 2021 war. Danke für eure Unterstützung, auch finanzieller Art. Der Rasenfunk bleibt paywall-sponsoren- und werbefrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de und ihr unterstützt damit nicht nur uns, sondern auch alle Gäste, die ein kleines Honorar bekommen für ihre Auftritte hier. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die das tun. Vielleicht gibt es ja den einen oder anderen, und die ein oder andere, die das jetzt noch tun möchte. Auch dafür herzlichen Dank. Kommt gut durch die Weihnachtszeit, bleibt gesund. Bitte bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.